on soit hyper nardelli merci avec nous
en direct sur arte france s'est exclu
ses excuses c'est une première pour
l'histoire de la belgique clairement
bonjour madame
il s'agit d' à peu près tout sauf des
excuses d un profond regret a été a été
donnée mais il n'y a pas d'excusé mode
excuses ne sont pas prononcés par le roi
etc intéressant d'ailleurs de voir dans
cette lettre qui est une lettre vous
l'avez rappelé qu' et qui est une
initiative personnelle du roi des belges
l'initiative oms il faut tempérer
évidemment en belgique le le roi règne
mais ne gouverne pas donc c'est
totalement sous contrôle du gouvernement
mais c'est une initiative personnelle ce
sont des regrets qui sont expliquées par
des excuses
il est intéressant de voir que on ne
mentionne pas le nom de léopold de la
colonisation n'est pas plus jugé il est
plutôt question d'un passé douloureux
commun c'est le mot commun qui revient
le plus donc il ne s'agit pas d' excuses
c'est une lettre d'une grande
intelligence d'une grande finesse
j'aimerais que l'on puisse retenir à
laquelle va répond un sens vous avez
raison on va s'y arrêter parce que ça
veut dire selon vous qui ne va pas
finalement nous voilà en général quand
on regrette des blessures du passé
le pendant serait peut-être de s'excuser
ou pas d'ailleurs en tout cas clairement
pour vous la subtilité ici est à noter
elle a un sens oui à nouveau c'est une
lettre d'une grande finesse d'une grande
intelligence à laquelle répond
d'ailleurs de manière aussi intelligente
est aussi fine le président de la
république démocratique du congo
il n'y a pas de demande d'excusés de la
part du congo le président nul n'a pas
demandé
et lorsqu'il reçoit cette lettre il y
répond ce sens remercie ya pas de
remerciements pour les regrets il y a la
volonté qui est exprimé par le par le
président de la république démocratique
du congo de parler d'histoire anneaux
enfant de cette histoire qui est une
histoire commune et sur base d'un
travail scientifique commun donc c'est
vraiment la continuation continuation
bardon d'une histoire commune c'est ça
qu'il faut retenir
même si les regrets sont son sang sont
évoqués pour pour ce qui est d'aider des
souffrances et des cruautés le mot kloet
et ans est employé mais nous ne sommes
pas dans les excuses
sept autres jetez plus fins et plus
intelligent c'est peut-être la seule
faille d'ailleurs c'est la finesse et
l'intelligence qui est rarement bien
comprise alors les atrocités v des
crimes coloniaux ça dit quelque chose en
tout cas sur sur l'histoire puisque
c'est très rare effectivement qu'un
gouvernement
c'est une première madame mais à nouveau
les montrent un sens vous lisiez vous
même il parle des actes de violence et
de cruauté qui ont été commis il n'y a
pas de généralisations donc on n'est
vraiment pas dans un système de
repentance rôle qu'on ne t'a pas un coup
de grands marteau c'est vraiment
beaucoup plus fin plus intelligence
la relation entre la belgique et le
congo est une relation qui vaut mieux
que ddd des stéréotypes qui vaut mieux
que que ce genre d'affirmation
l'empêchent ses regrets ont été
formulées à dans un climat de tension
notamment aux états unis qui a ramené le
débat sur le passé notamment des empires
coloniaux sur la table en tout cas en
belgique admettre publiquement que les
pays colonisés ont souffert ont été
spoliés est ce que ça peut clairement
permettre d'apaiser le climat
il n'y a pas de question de de
spoliation c'est important parce que
vous voyez même dans dordogne dans ce
que nous disons aux vous et moi
notre discussion est polluée par des
mots qu'on a entendues et qui sont qui
sont rattachés alors à longueur de
journée il n'est pas question de deux
explications
ne pas en avoir les compétences est un
sujet délicat je me garderai bien
effectivement de refaire l'histoire ici
la réponse la réponse qui est donnée à
nouveau la lettre et intelligente fine
la réponse est intelligente et fine ce
sont des déclarations aussi bien du roi
des belges que du président du congo qui
sont des déclarations ou bi et orbi si
vous voulez à la cité au reste du monde
on voit très bien qu'il parle leur
propre peuple qui parle aussi au peuple
en phase où la belgique ou le congo est
la référence qui est fait par le par le
président du congo est intéressant parce
qu'il vit qu'il faut parler à nos
enfants mais sur base d'un travail
scientifique commun ça veut donc dire
que il parle notamment la diaspora
africaine dont quelques représentants
ont été présentés dans votre petit sujet
avant en leur disant on doit parler de
l'histoire de notre histoire commune
mais sur base d'un travail scientifique
on ne peut pas dire tout et n'importe
quoi et c'est vrai que les tensions dont
vous parliez ont fait émerger des propos
totalement faut donc un travail
scientifique commun une histoire commune
et à nouveau c'est un moment je pense
extrêmement important qui montre si la
personnalité royal vous savez en
belgique le roi n'a pas beaucoup
l'occasion d'exprimer à nouveau il ne
gouverne pas et on voit chez lui une
grande finesse et juste que je trouve
extraordinaire c'est que la réponse du
congo est à la hauteur fine et
intelligente c'est ça que j'aimerais que
l'on puisse se retenir ce soir puisque
vous l'avez dit en tout cas plusieurs
fois comment ont réagi les belges cette
sortie de leur roi écoutez je crois
qu'il est il est un peu tôt pour le dire
et à nouveau jeudi le souvent le le
débat est un peu pollué parce que par
des mots un peu outrancier de telle
sorte qu'on est amené à prendre des
positions sans avoir lu je ne savais pas
quel est ce que seraient vos questions
dont je m'apprêtais à lire la
déclaration royal vous l'avez vous vous
l'avez fait vous l'avez fait pour moi et
on est donc sans cette lecture que sans
cette compréhension c'est difficile de
réagir mais je crois que cette
déclaration est très très bien a très
très bien reçus évidemment merci
beaucoup
lui d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
rt france merci à vous